[Music]
matt is in lancaster pennsylvania hi
matt how are you good how you doing dave
better than i deserve what's up
awesome uh first i just want to say
thank you uh in 2015
me and my wife found you and paid off
120 000
uh in 2018 so thank you for that good
for you
yeah look forward to seeing you when the
mortgages paid off awesome
currently uh i'm a nurse at a hospital
in lancaster that is going to be
mandating uh the coveted vaccine
which i'm not sure if i'm going to get
it yet so i'm looking at possibly doing
a career change
we have an 18 month old and um
our second baby is due august 24th
um if i don't get the vaccine it would
be uh
my firing date would be september 1st
we're in baby steps 4 five and six we
have about
uh 55 000 in retirement with my work
we both have iras that have about 3 000
each we're putting in money for our
first child's college fund
monthly and apparently reporting about
400 extra
on the mortgage uh so i guess my
question is how much is in the emergency
fund
uh the emergency fund right now has
fifteen thousand dollars
and what's your household income
i bring home gross about 63 and then
take home for my wife she intern
business she's bringing
around like a thousand to 1500 a month
take home
i don't know what her gross is okay we
probably bring home
about 4 500 a month
okay so august july
and the rest of june so you've got
75 days correct yep
okay all right
um for them to either change their mind
or you get a different nursing job why
don't you just get a different nursing
job
um it's a shortage one nurse
two i know um so the
thinking is that's possibility um so i'm
really into finances after
discovering you um and i have been in
talks with my financial advisor about
becoming a financial advisor myself if
that would fall through
and i'm also looking at other nursing
jobs the only
issue that i see with that is it's one
of the largest companies
hospital-wide um in pennsylvania on the
philadelphia side
and i believe everyone's kind of just
watching to see
how many nurses and people leave um well
that's happened that's happening
everywhere
okay yeah and the point is and you
you're well aware of this i don't need
to tell you this
but i'm just going to remind you of what
you already know they have there's a lot
of places that have nurses that are not
hospitals
yeah that's true
yeah so i guess i could do that yeah
yeah because here's the thing
here's the thing you need to make the
jump to financial advisor from strength
not desperation and weakness and yeah so
that's my
i also yeah so i've been offered from
other people
that know that i'm in to finances and
stuff they
have talked to me about training me to
be an accountant and stuff like that and
i don't want to that's what me and my
wife have discussed i don't want to be
taking any kind of job out of
desperation
just kind of like listening to you and
stuff like that
yeah i think you need to finish out
getting real clear on what this next
move from nursing
is and you need to make the jump from
nursing
um so what i think is going to happen is
i think you're going to find another
nursing job in the next three weeks
okay because you're actually going to
start looking
yeah do you think now do you think i
should wait
like say my start date would be in
september
no i think i think if these bozos are
willing to put you on the street i'm
willing to put them on the street
okay that's kind of my feeling too do
you think um
now with that would you stop investing
because we're investing 15
no i think i'd go get a job making more
than i make now
and quit the bad job with the bad people
okay all right so here's what's
happening okay
you're this is happening all over
america
yeah you know we're we've got large
companies
mandating vaccines and people are
leaving them in
droves okay so hospitals i've talked to
uh 20 people in healthcare in the past
three or four weeks
and what's happening is that they're
doing stuff like they're talking about
doing with you and
and the nurses are saying uh uh i'm not
taking this thing
i'm out i i listen i'm not signing up
so then what happens is they take where
they've already got a nursing shortage
at that hospital
and they exasperate it and then they're
once they once they make the decision
then they go back and undo the decision
because they realize how screwed they
are because half their people walk out
it's like causing a strike
yeah and that's what's kind of going on
here yeah they're i got a feeling as
soon as you find a job
they're going to change their mind yeah
yeah but i'm not sure i want to stay
there anyway if they're if they're
willing to put the muscle on me like
that
yeah that's so again being in the
financial situation we are thanks to you
guys
um i feel like i can leave well
definitely a lot of my coworkers that
feel yeah you can leave because you can
go make
more yeah because you're in you're in a
fabulous field nursing is a fabulous
field you
you know you're only as secure not as
some company providing you security
you're only as secure as your ability to
go land another thing doing it
and nursing you can always land another
thing doing it so you've got security
because of your knowledge base and
because of your licensing
and and because of your willingness to
do what you do and thank you for doing
it by the way
but um yeah i had a friend of mine the
other day he's working for a huge
corporation he'd been there for years
and he was going to retire in two years
and they said you have to have a vaccine
to
come back into the office and he said
okay i'll just retire now
and he's one of their top sales guys and
they lost him
you people in corporate america are
idiots y'all are idiots
you're just dumb it's unbelievable and
it has nothing to do with you really
think somebody's gonna get sick you're
just
virtue signaling you just want to look
like
i'm sensitive you're not sensitive
you're corporate america
you're idiots you treat a guy like this
who's been
serving people like a slab of meat and
you know what he's gonna do
he's gonna walk on you that's what he's
going to do and that's what you deserve
godly unbelievable look if you want to
take a vaccine i'm not mad at you but
somebody
mandating that you have to do that or
you lose your job
hey they deserve to lose the talent they
deserve for talent to turn on their heel
and walk out the
door wire see around ramsey we got a
rule
we don't have a rule
you can wear a mask if you want to you
don't have to wear a mask if you don't
want to
you can take your temperature at the
door if you want to or you cannot take
your temperature at the door if you want
to
and everybody's getting along and nobody
died
hitting this is a wonderful thing and
just but just don't be
pissing and telling everybody else how
they got to live
a bunch of people telling everybody else
how they got to live it's a debt
mind your own business this is the
ramsay show